troisième point sur la situation dans
notre département il ya les crises
sanitaires que nous traversons et que je
tenais à faire directement avec vous ces
deux dernières semaines nous nous sommes
concentrés essentiellement sur trois
choses tout d'abord évidemment les
prestations nous sommes assurés que
l'ensemble des prestations dont nous
avons la responsabilité je pense aux
allocations mensuelles ou au revenu de
solidarité active soit bien versé demain
samedi 4 avril et nous en assurer avec
nos partenaires bancaires que l'ensemble
des allocataires bénéficiaires pourront
en disposer
deuxième point les ehpad vous savez que
c'est la règle du confinement absolue
qui prévaudrait en département comme
dans de nombreux départements pour
protéger les plus vulnérables d'entre
nous les personnes âgées
nous allons mettre à disposition des
établissements dès la semaine prochaine
un certain nombre de tablettes pour
permettre qu'il y ait un lien avec les
familles et les résidents
enfin la distribution de masques plus de
vingt mille masques ont été déjà
distribué cette semaine et je remercie
l'ensemble des agents du département qui
ont contribué d'autres livraisons sont
attendues la semaine prochaine et nous
continuerons à en faire bénéficier les
établissements recevant des personnes en
situation de handicap ou de la
protection de l'enfance et des
résidences autonomie qui relève de notre
responsabilité
un mot pour vous dire que en cette
période de confinement nous avons décidé
l'accès gratuit à la lecture numérique
en lien avec la bibliothèque
départementale de la vienne une pensée
pour nos amis de moselle en remerciant
tous celles et tous ceux qui ont
contribué au convoi sanitaire du
grand-est vers le chu de poitiers
merci aux médecins du chu de poitiers à
l'ensemble du personnel soignant aux
pompiers disent qu'ils ont contribué et
puis aussi au personnel de l'aéroport
qui ont permis le premier réveil de m
lyon la semaine dernière enfin une
pensée aussi pour tous les acteurs
économiques
nous allons être très attentifs à la
reprise de leurs activités d'ores et
déjà avec celles pour lesquelles nous
avons un marché certaines avances ont
été faites pour leur permettre de
continuer à fonctionner le plus
normalement possible vous dire aussi que
nous allons être attentifs à pouvoir
vous répondre à toutes les questions que
vous allez opposé par la création d'un
guichet mais d'ores et déjà sur la page
du département la vienne 86 point fr
vous trouverez maximum de réponses en
lien avec les difficultés que nous pose
le coville 19